I was just
there was a moment that I went like
silent when you were talking to him
because I was like dang man
it [snorts] seemed like he like reverted
back
to like that cult mindset that Bob mode
and it was just like dang did we lose
him?
You know?
Cuz we've been praying for him ever
since.
So I I came prepared this time cuz I
>> [laughter]
>> I rewatched the video yesterday and I
saw where God logic switched the topic.
Switched the topic?
>> [laughter]
>> So
but first of all I want to kind of help
the audience to kind of understand what
goes on in the mentality of a Jehovah
Witness when you guys are questioning
like us, right? Could you guys give me
about 5 minutes to kind of give us
>> Not 5 minutes. Maybe just like one
[laughter] I don't know how long it
would take cuz I would pull up
scriptures. I don't just want to ramble
back and forth, right? Yeah, just just
if you if you can just give a quick
>> I can hear your your your co-host but I
can't hear you. I know we can all hear
him but he's just having issues with his
stuff. He's
he's the one I've been waiting for.
I don't I don't know if he is going to
go away again but I can hear you right
now. You can hear me now, okay.
>> Yeah. So look, if you if you can give
like a quick little maybe about a minute
I'll let you go.
You got just about a minute, that's it.
Okay, basically I want to say like God
has used people throughout history, you
know, like Moses, the the judges, kings
and then the apostles and so forth. So
with Jehovah's Witnesses we believe uh
in Matthew 24:45
that Jesus selected a faithful and
discreet slave who is supposed to feed
all the Christians.
And uh
uh based on what I was saying the other
day was in Daniel 12 there's a verse
which says "As of you Daniel keep this
scroll a secret and then they will be be
revealed during the end times." And as
you you guys already know the end times
are described as earthquakes, wars and
so forth and so forth. And no nowhere
else in history did that start since
1914 to right now. Meaning we're now
living during the end times. So the
faithful slave can understand some stuff
because the
the new information is being revealed. I
think Proverbs 4:18 says that
a spiritual person or a righteous
person's wisdom will keep increasing as
as the time goes by. So when it comes to
the Holy Spirit I've been hearing you
guys go back and forth and it's clearly
a very complicated subject. No, it's
not. We we all believe we all believe
that you know there's demons and the
Holy Spirit and you know good spirit
working to either enlighten people or
or hide things from people. So that's
why we need to rely on those selected
people who can understand it because
>> [laughter]
>> Avery what's interesting about what he's
saying though is the fact that the Watch
Tower Society
has proclaimed three times
the end date of when the world is going
to end in the past 100 years and they
were wrong every single time.
>> Every time.
Like
and again they can still
>> I have your catechism right here.
They can still have errors in decision
making because they are human beings.
What about false prophecies? But
>> Exactly. But is there So do you guys
believe that they should be like
like a leader in Christian world where
we can all
come
>> Could they give false prophecies?
No, they shouldn't be all right making
false prophets left and right. They have
to be of pure hearted, you know, like
>> Can they give Can they give any false
prophecies?
Like in in what sense? Like like a a
malicious person or trying to hurt
people?
>> Like this. God told us and revealed to
us this will happen.
And then it doesn't happen.
So that's a false prophecy.
Can a true servant and messenger of God
give false prophecies?
At the at the time did they believe it
to be true and then only God revealed it
later to be incorrect? If [laughter]
they if they genuinely believed it like
so Proverbs Proverbs 4:18
>> Wait wait you're not answering the
question.
Can
a messenger of God give
false prophecies?
No, they shouldn't be able to. Yeah.
Exactly. So if somebody gives false
prophecy then they are a false prophet,
right? Okay, I'll give you that one.
Yeah.
So the Watch Tower Society the Watch
Tower Society, brother Mhm.
three times
gave false prophecy
and then tried to tried to disguise it
as "Oh well, you know, Jehovah gives
more light over time." No.
It's a false prophecy. Call it what it
is and you need to see it for what it
is. Do not fall for this cult mentality.
Like like when when Israelite used to
have judges and kings did any of them
do something wrong while they were in
charge? Or they didn't give false false
prophecies.
It does.
>> No, like like human error per se like
greed and cuz cuz as human beings are
imperfect we can once we taste power
might be moved to do
something extra than In Deuteronomy
chapter 18 when you read 15 to 21
if a person
if a prophet speaks in the name of
Jehovah and he gives a false prophecy,
do you know what the punishment is?
I mean Old Testament so I think it's
probably death.
>> tongue will be severed.
Oh.
>> [laughter]
>> It was
It was capital punishment, my friend. So
there's no there is no leeway with this.
Avery's absolutely correct, man. And you
>> Every So are you telling me in your in
your Christian journey, right? At some
point you believe something and then as
you studied the Bible you realized that
you were wrong at something. And
are you sure you never repeated or
uttered those things with a genuine
genuine heart saying that hey, this is
this is how I understand this. This is
the truth. And then
>> Yes. after you spoke with your co-host
right there and said "No, actually it's
actually like this." And then from then
on instead of letting your greed
keep you in your false world you decided
to change and say this is the new thing
I believe. So that's how it's done like
we all agree.
>> You You asked me a question. Let me
answer you.
Yes, I have been wrong in my theology
before, my friend. I have been wrong in
my understanding multiple times even to
this day.
But never have I ever came
out and said that God has said to me and
given me this understanding. God
revealed this
false understanding to me.
I never came out and said that. That's
because you Do you understand the
difference between having a personal
understanding or opinion
versus claiming to be hearing from God
that that's where you're getting your
understanding?
Yeah.
So the the Watch So the Watch Tower
Society isn't some innocent Christian
bystander who just got something wrong
and had a false understanding. They
claimed that God was giving them
revelation and giving them the dates and
giving them the events and what will
happen.
And so in that in that respect they were
claiming to be the mouthpiece of God
warning everybody of what is happening.
Mhm. But it was false. So they spoke for
God when God did not tell them to speak.
When God did not give them these words.
They are false prophets by definition.
I mean I I understand I understand what
you're saying but with great uh power
comes great responsibility How's there a
butt after that? because you were not
you were not selected by God to be the
spokesperson. So once once you're
selected by God to be his spokesperson
[snorts]
and since today God doesn't act in
miracles so the the person taking the
lead still has has the burden to to
ponder on the Bible and really really
read and with a genuine heart says
>> Why should we believe you over Joseph
Smith? Why not just take Joseph Smith?
That way we can at least get four wives.
Well, you have to also look at the
motives of the people. I think you you'd
speak a lot on the on the Muslims and
you can clearly see the motives of the
founders of the Muslims wanted to get
the access to the women and kill as
people as they wanted. But if you look
at the founders of the Jehovah's
Witnesses they didn't profit on any of
whatever they were
>> you talking about? That's a lie. They
made so much money.
Some of your leaders got mansions upon
mansions due to the funds that its
followers gave them cuz they thought the
world was ending. So they gave their
funds to them and they built mansions
off of that money. There's one of those
mansions is out here in California to
this day. We can go in San Diego and go
pop up to one of those mansions right
now.
Okay, let's let's let's stick to on
doctrine now then.
Cuz
cuz
>> [laughter]
>> cuz we can we can talk about that
because at the end of the day somebody
has to say, "Okay, this is the belief
that aligns with me the most and what
this one what makes more sense." But but
but but my problem here, brother, my
problem my problem with with with you is
is that you can you will take a false
prophet.
Like like you don't you wouldn't know
what would be what what to follow
because anybody can be a false prophet
for you and you'll just say, "Oh, new
light." Exactly. Uh doesn't the Bible in
in my I'm sorry if I can't recall the
specific verse, but I know you probably
will recall it. There's a verse that
says the people are taking the lead will
be held accounted
for for the things that they teach or do
to the
Yeah, so so as as
as followers
the Bible ask us to obey the people
taking the lead. It's not our place
>> Where does Where does Where does the
Bible tell you to follow false prophets?
Exactly.
Well
like once you have established that God
selected them, then if they mislead you
as long as you obeyed, you did your part
as a Christian. But then they will
answer to Jesus when the time comes for
misleading people. No, you too will
answer
because God gives God will hand you over
to the desires of your heart. And if the
desires of your heart is to follow after
these false prophets over the true God,
then he's going to hand you over to
that, man.
And we don't want that to happen, bro.
Let's take a look at this really quick.
Your smile is way too beautiful to be
doing that. Honestly, I'm playing with
you. Let's take a look Let's take a look
at this really quick.
You want me to read that? No,
my my share, you there?
Uh yeah,
let's see.
22:22 Yeah. When a prophet speaks in the
name of the Lord, if the word does not
come to pass or come through, that is a
word that the Lord has not spoken. The
prophet has spoken in presumptuously.
You need not be afraid of him.
So, according to God, are you supposed
to listen to a false prophet?
No.
So, why are you listening to a false
prophet? I don't think Okay, we need to
establish that I think the the current
governing body of they've never claimed
to be prophet. They actually says they
can error in in decision that that
they're not uh
uh infallible like they can't be
speaking the truth all the time. So,
they can tell the the Jehovah Witness
that, "Hey, this is this is what we need
to do." and then it turned out to be
wrong. They've They've admitted that.
>> You're following people who can who
continued this line and the start up by
false prophets and continued to be a
continuation.
The same governing body, the same
Kingdom Hall and Watch Tower Society.
Yes, they edit things be because they
get called out for their mistakes and
their false prophecies. But they're
still the false prophet nonetheless,
man. They're the same entity.
Watch the Watch Tower Society. In logic,
they're still acting the role of prophet
because what did the prophet do?
Communicates the words of God by virtue
of
mistranslating
the their Bible purposely
and they're putting their uh they're
putting themselves in the seat of God.
Cuz they're adding to the words of God.
Brother, you got to there's no way that
you
don't see don't see this, man. The the
scripture gives gives you warnings and
give you a clear
like like
the the scripture gives it away to where
you don't have to be deceived and
misled. He The scripture warns you
against false prophets like Muhammad,
like Joseph Smith, like Charles Taze
Russell, and the Watch Tower Society.
So, what's what's the one falsehood that
you might say that we believe as
Jehovah's Witnesses right now cuz I'm
pretty sure the stuff preacher saying is
a long time ago and like I gave an
example that even the chosen people of
God themself error during their their
tenure, you know, like When When When
When When When When
When did When did David When did Solomon
When did Moses When did Malachi When did
Isaiah When did Samuel When did
any of these prophets ever say, "Hey,
God gave me this revelation. This is
going to happen." or this is supposed to
happen or this is the truth and it
turned out to be false and never
happened?
I've been running through my head I can
think of Moses hitting the rock three
times when they were told it to eat from
>> say God told me to hit the rock?
I know he said he said he provided
the the water when that was a problem.
But you're But you're not But you're not
listening. I need you to listen,
brother.
I need you to listen. I I need you cuz
I've been
I'm being patient with you, bro.
I'm I'm I'm inviting you on. I'm giving
you more time than I give to anybody
else.
Cuz I care about you. So, I need you to
wake your mind up
and listen to what I'm asking you.
Did Moses
claim that God told him to hit the rock?
three times
>> No, I don't I don't I don't remember
that part. I think he prayed that God
people need water and then God told him
to do something
>> didn't say, "Thus says the Lord." and
then get it wrong. Do the Do the
opposite thing, right? Yeah, he didn't
say that. No prophet in the Bible, no
prophet of God ever said, "Thus says the
Lord." and it didn't happen as they said
it would happen or they some falsehood
took place, correct?
Yeah, no, I can't I can't recall any.
Right. But with the Watch Tower Society
you have the governing body who claims
to be that faithful and discreet witness
who receives revelation from God and
inspiration from God similar to how the
apostles did and they got things wrong.
They got false prophecies. Thus says
Jehovah and it never happened. Thus says
Jehovah and they're changing scriptures.
Thus says Jehovah and they're corrupting
interpretation. They're all false
prophets, brother.
So, I guess if you can prove one thing
for me, then I will believe you because
is progressive revelation a true
teaching or not because all that can be
answered
>> Progressive revelation
Yeah.
>> Progressive revelation from where? From
God, you know, where Okay, sure. It
Progressive revelation is real.
Yeah. Progressive revelation meaning
revelation Yeah. The a revelation is
received and then more revelation Yeah.
comes later, right? Yeah, so they could
have believed that in the '90s and then
we believe
>> So, hold on. It starts with true
revelation at first, right?
Yeah, yeah, it needs to be true from
God.
>> So, progressive revelation is based on
truth.
If it starts off as false, then it ain't
progressive revelation, is it? Amen.
[clears throat]
If
if what if it was true at the time cuz
they it needs to they they faithful and
discreet slave says they gave us food at
the proper time. Like how do you prove
that at the time it was not true?
Revelation chapter 22:18-19. For I
testify to everyone who hears the words
of the prophecy of this book, if anyone
adds to these things, God will add to
him the plagues that are written in this
book. And if anyone takes
[clears throat] away from the words of
the book of the prophecy, God shall take
away his part from the book of life,
from the holy city, and from the things
which are written in the book.
Where is
I think the Watch Tower is allowed to
add to things to explain it more from
the Bible.
So, it's not adding in the Bible. It's
outside the the Bible.
The 144,000
are going to be in heaven with Jesus,
right? Yes. And then if you're not a
part of the 144,000,
the rest of the Jehovah Witnesses will
be living where? On Earth, correct?
>> On Earth, yes. And then every thousand
years or so
Jesus will come and make an appearance
on Earth just to say, "What's up?" to
the Jehovah Witnesses on Earth, right?
Well, he'll be ruling for 1,000 years
before he hands over the kingdom
>> I'm talking about at the end. I'm
talking about it at the end when he's
with the 144,000 in heaven.
Okay? He's going to be with them for
what?
About a thousand years and then every
what? Every thousand years or so, he's
going to come down to Earth and say
hello to all you other Jehovah
Witnesses, right? Yes.
Okay, your heaven is my hell.
A heaven absent of Jesus is my hell,
Avery's hell. Do you understand that?
That's the first time I'm hearing that.
I'll tell you that.
Please, brother.
>> Can you Can you explain a little bit
better right there?
I'm just going to I'm going to encourage
you just research what I just said,
okay? It's it's it's in your it's in
your works. Mhm. Okay? This is what your
scholars have said. I have 20 I have
about 15 books right here from your
scholars.
Just remember what I said and look at
it, but remember your
heaven is mine and Avery's hell because
a heaven absent of Jesus is hell itself.
Just want to say that.
Mhm.
Wow.
Okay. I I hear you guys uh
So, what
>> out of love, bro. We love you, man.
That's why we're saying this.
Mhm.
>> [clears throat]
>> I mean I I I can clearly see how why you
would say if you teach one thing and you
say it's from God and then that thing
doesn't come through, then uh
then that's that's the definition of a
false prophet. But I I don't remember
them claiming to ever be prophet,
though.
They never said they were prophet.
>> claim They literally claim to be the
mouthpiece of Jehovah, bro. Mhm. They
literally claim to be the mouthpiece and
spokesman of Jehovah,
the ones who receive revelation from
Jehovah and inspiration from Jehovah.
That's what they claim.
That's who they claim to be.
So, all the other religions, they don't
have anything that they can be wrong on?
They are right on everything else?
>> They're going to hell, too, bro.
Are you Was that a real question?
Yeah, cuz like um you know, like when I
examine the Jehovah Witnesses, they have
a lot of stuff that are right compared
to
>> have anything right. There's nothing
that they have right. You know you you
know who seemed like they had a lot of
stuff right, too? Mhm. You want to know
who seemed like they had a lot of stuff
right? Who?
That serpent in the garden. Bro, I was
just thinking that. Yeah. That serpent
in the garden. Didn't he seem right when
he said, "Well, you won't surely die."
Mhm. Right? Yeah. You What What What
What What's going to happen is is you're
going to become like God and you're
going to know good and evil.
Sounds about right, right? That's what
happened.
Adam and Eve knew right from wrong,
right? They knew good They knew the They
knew experienced good and evil.
So, the serpent seemed right in what he
was saying, didn't he? Mhm.
Yeah, I I see I see what you're saying.
Like uh Satan uses uh half truth and
it's more lie to to deceive people.
Exactly.
Mhm. He covers the lie in a truth
which makes the I mean, which makes the
lie even more more powerful and
deceptive. Question. The The Lord's The
Lord's prayer, it says
"Let your kingdom come."
When that happen, when everybody is in
heaven, who is the kingdom coming to?
And I think in Revelation 21, where it
says neither there will be mourning nor
crying, it says the former things have
passed away. Where the people are not
crying anymore, people used to cry
there. And people only cry on Earth. So,
you wouldn't say former things when
everybody is in heaven. This is my
Jehovah Witness understanding of why we
say we'll be on Earth.
>> They're not going to be Explain those
two phrases Well, those those two verses
that kind of make it look like So, it
says pray this, you know, our prayer
like "Let your kingdom come." Whose
kingdom? God's kingdom is in heaven and
it's going to come here on Earth to
rule.
And then, once the God's kingdom is
ruling, that means there won't be any
more suffering, no more mourning, no
more sorrow. Former things have passed
away. And they say you will go to look
at where the wicked people were and you
won't see them anymore. Meaning these
people are on Earth walking around. And
I think in Isaiah or Psalms it says the
meek will inherit the the Earth. And it
says the heavens are for angels and the
the Earth is for humans. So, when you
read those verses, how do you come up
with the conclusion that no, we will all
leave this dirt and go in heaven?
Because your Jesus is no longer Jesus
anymore. He's right now Michael the
Archangel with the memory of Jesus, but
he's no longer Jesus. You know that,
right?
He's an angel now again.
And therefore, he's going to be in the
heavenly abode.
That's why. He's no longer Jesus.
He was an angel, the angel Michael, who
then became a human, Jesus, and then at
his ascension to heaven, he became the
angel Michael again and he has the
memory of Jesus on Earth. That's what
your Watch Tower Society teaches, which
is why he's going to be in heaven and
he's going to make an appearance every
once in a while you're on Earth.
Yeah, I I never understand the the
Michael part because
uh it's just a
uh simile where it says oh, he has a
roaring voice like an archangel, but it
doesn't say he's an angel per se. So,
like that
You want to see, brother, how powerful
Yeah. Like they say
uh for you to get everlasting life, you
have to have the the foundation right.
All the extra teachings are just like
extra, but what saves you is the
foundation that uh you know, like what
uh the salvay What causes people to get
saved? So, like for example, the
teaching that Jehovah Witnesses teach us
saying
not everybody's going to go to heaven.
And the reasoning that we give is those
scriptures in the Old Testament that
make it sound like the Earth will be
here forever. But if everybody's in
heaven, will be Earth be empty? Or even
the The people will be on Earth. Those
that are not part of the 144,000,
they will be on Earth
while Michael the Archangel, so-called
Jesus, will be making an appearance
every once in a while However, those
that go to hell, what happens to them?
They get annihilated, right? Because you
guys don't believe in the eternal hell.
You believe that once someone is thrown
in the lake of fire, they then
evaporate. As a matter of fact, hold on
one second. As a matter of fact, what
you guys believe in is once you die
right now,
okay? God forbid, but once you die right
now, your soul ceases to exist. You
don't exist anymore. You cease to exist
until the resurrection, in which then
your spirit will be recreated and joined
to your body. That's what you guys
believe.
Which is what the Seventh-day Adventists
believe as well, which they got from you
guys.
Which means if Jesus paid
the debts of man, the debt of sin,
>> [clears throat]
>> the debt of sin on behalf of man by
becoming man in every which way like
Hebrews chapter 2:14-16 says, that means
when he died, he ceased to exist for 3
days according to your theology.
If you're going to be consistent.
Sorry, guys. My my phone died. I asked a
couple questions with those two
scriptures uh It's okay, buddy. I don't
know if you guys heard me and if I can
get your answer on that because that
will actually really answer one of the
biggest question I've ever had because
uh uh if I ask my my mom is not a
believing Jehovah Witness. If I ask her,
"Mom, when you die, where will you go?"
She says heaven. And then
uh I When at the Kingdom Hall we read
scriptures that shows that God is
promising uh
human beings meek, not not uh bad
humans, good humans that they will
possess the Earth forever. And uh and
the Earth belongs to humans. Heavens is
for angels.
And then in Revelation it says those
kings will be ruling over the Earth.
And so, I don't I don't understand the
Earth will still be there. And And then
if I ask my mom, she says she will go to
heaven. If she will she be part of the
kings or will she be part of the people
who are being ruled?
Uh or like when the Lord's prayer says,
"Let your kingdom come." It's coming
where the humans are living.
Yeah, but let let me ask you a question.
Why do you want to go to heaven?
I I mean, I don't have the heavenly
calling. And if you know if you're going
to have the
What [clears throat] would be here
Can you define really quick for me, just
5 seconds, can you define
heaven for me? What would your heaven
look like that you believe that God will
grant you?
What would that heaven look like?
[clears throat]
>> believe that I'm going to go to heaven.
I believe that I'll be in on paradise
Earth. I will live forever like what God
intended for Adam and Eve for me.
>> What is that
What does that mean to you? Sorry to
interrupt you. What does that mean to
you?
Well, the main big achievement is you
will get to live forever and there won't
be any sickness, no more suffering, no
more war, no more earthquakes. That's
That's the heaven. There will be plenty
of
>> what our
Do you want to know what our heaven
looks like?
Is it biblical? Like what I described
right there is biblical.
>> Our heaven Our heaven Mhm.
is Jesus Christ. That's all we want.
That's our heaven. We want Jesus
and that's it. As a matter of fact,
if I don't have Jesus,
I'd rather be thrown in hell. And I'm
telling you, the fires of hell will pale
in comparison to living one moment
without the love of Jesus Christ. You
understand?
I want to be where Jesus is. I want to
see my savior.
That's our heaven. That's a Christian
heaven, where Jesus is.
I don't care about anything else. As a
matter of fact,
look at what Paul says right here. And
it's so beautiful, man. In Romans
chapter 8:31, he says
the following. He says, "What then shall
we say to these things? If God is for
you, who can be against us? He, the
Father, he who did not spare his own
son, but delivered him up for us all,
how shall he not with him also give us
all things? With him give us all
things."
So, brother,
just like the good old song says, and I
think you had a bad connection again,
but once again,
the song says in Psalm 86, it says that
I'd rather live a day as a doorman a
doormat in the kingdom of heaven
than to live apart
from God forever and ever. Now, I'm
paraphrasing the verse. I'd rather be a
doormat in the kingdom of heaven. Let
people step over me, just so I'm in the
presence of God.
That's the kind of attitude we should
have, man.
I understand what you're saying, but if
you can
stick to the questions that I I I gave
you, cuz those are scriptures that I'm
quoting. I just I just don't know the
exact scripture. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. I'm sorry, guys. I I have something
that I I wanted to share with you, cuz I
was I was just looking at these
Watchtower magazines from back in the
'70s, okay?
And I wanted you to show you what the
watch what your Watchtower Society was
claiming. It's crazy. It's like we got
to You know how with Muslims we got to
go into their Hadith and their
commentary? It's like we got to do the
same with Jehovah's Witnesses. We got to
go into your magazines and Watchtower
Society and stuff like that. So,
I just want to show you that they
claimed to be prophet the prophet of
God, okay?
So, Oh, that one that if if you have
proof of that, then then the when they
said one thing and then it didn't
happen, then they won't have any excuse.
Yeah.
>> Of course. Of course, man.
>> think they've claimed that.
What's Oh, yeah, they did.
So,
>> [laughter]
>> look at this. This is
I'm going to I'm going to zoom in so we
can see it clearly.
Oops. Wrong thing.
1 2 3 4.
All right.
Click on this.
1 2 3.
Still a bigger bigger bigger bigger.
All right, here it is.
Bigger.
All right. You see the magazine?
Yeah, I see it.
>> words, but
I know the words are small, probably. I
don't know if you can see it, but I'm
going to read the relevant parts, all
right? Cuz the whole thing is about the
prophet was among them.
And how the Watchtower is claiming to be
the prophet of on Earth among the
people, okay? Watch.
So, we go down to this first red box.
So, does Jehovah have a prophet to help
them, to warn them of dangers, and to
declare things to come?
And then here's the section, identifying
the prophet.
That these questions can be answered in
the affirmative, meaning yes.
Who is this prophet?
>> [clears throat]
>> The clergy of the so-called Christian
nations hold themselves before the
people as being the ones commissioned to
speak for God.
>> [snorts]
>> But as pointed out in the previous issue
uh of this magazine,
they have failed God and and failed as
proclaimers of his kingdom by approving
a man-made political organization, the
League of Nations, now the United
Nations,
as  and  the political
expression of the kingdom of God on
Earth.
However, Jehovah did not let the people
of Christendom,
as led by the clergy, go without being
warned that the League was a counterfeit
substitute for the real kingdom of God.
He had a prophet to warn them.
This prophet was not one man, but was a
body of men and women. The governing
body, right?
It was the small group of footstep
followers of Jesus Christ, known at that
time as International Bible Students.
Today, they are known as Jehovah's
Christian Witnesses.
So, the governing body here
is claiming to be the prophet of today
warning the nations.
This is the Watchtower Society
uh announcing Jehovah's kingdom, April
1st, 1972,
number seven, issue number seven.
Page
page 197.
Yeah, wasn't aware of this magazine. I
mean, we
I became aware like studying really hard
in 2018 coming right now, but this is
way old, so I didn't know that
they have claimed to be a prophet,
because right now they say that they are
no prophet and they can error in uh
in in judgment or in in teaching on
doctrine and stuff like that. So,
I I don't I didn't know that they
claimed that they were prophets before
in the past.
Uh So, in claiming to be prophets and
they're giving false prophecies, not
once, not twice, three times, multiple
times, they're giving false prophecies,
brother.
And this is the society. This is what
you're following. You're following the
Watchtower, the Jehovah's Witnesses, the
Watchtower Society. This is who you're
following. You're following a governing
body of false prophets, bro.
So, what do I do? This is what I've
known my whole life, though. So, like I
mean, with you are showing stuff like
this.
I I
If if the the core foundation
they don't meet the the test you said
right there that they have to be killed,
then
I don't know God logic.
>> [laughter]
>> I mean, coming to this, I I knew that I
might hear something that I don't want
to hear, but
But you But you came anyway.
But you came anyway, because the Holy
Spirit I'm telling you, man. The Holy
Spirit works. And he And Christ loves
those, man. So, how do you know how do
you know when they're lying or when
they're telling a lie when they tell you
that they this is coming from the heart,
this is the truth at that time? Like
they are not
physically trying to lie to you. Then
how how do you
>> though. That's the point. They They lied
on They lied on purpose. They lied. They
claimed to be God's
God's prophets.
They claimed to be God's prophets
warning the nations on Earth.
>> [clears throat]
>> And they lied.
Told you to
>> this affect us, the rank and file,
though? It's Isn't that on the judgment
is only on the leaders, though?
The judgment The judgment is worse on
the leaders,
but judgment is also upon you, who, when
you find that these are false prophets
and you and you remain with them instead
of abandoning them and following God's
truth, judgment is on you as well.
Now, today we don't we don't preach what
they used to preach over there. So, how
do we know that what they are preaching
today is also a lie? Like uh
cuz
cuz I don't want to be preaching out the
truth, you know? I don't want to I don't
want to preach out the lie.
They are still the society of false
prophets, brother. They're the same
entity. Nothing's changed except people
just get elected into that same
governing body. They're still the false
prophets carrying on the false prophets
and uh
denying the word of God.
Lying to you about who Jesus is. Lying
to you about the gospel. Changing the
words. Hiding information from you. Mhm.
You You've never seen this this stuff
before, because they hid this They hide
these magazines from you guys, man.
They don't They don't display this to
you. At this point, no no religion is
true religion if you
if you look at the their past like going
back, right? Like is it okay to now be
like those people What do you call them?
Non-denomination? No, this This is what
This is what you look at. From
non-non-denominational.
>> [laughter]
>> What What you What you look at What you
look at, Mychael? What you look at
is you look at Christ.
You look at Christ and you follow
Christ. Don't follow men. Amen. You're
following men.
And a body That is what they said, a
body of men and women. That's who you're
following. You're not following Christ.
The in Colossians it say
keep on associating with one another,
and you know, uh keeping to to encourage
one another, meaning like the meeting
together is a church is still important.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Fellowship.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, brother. There's a difference
between fellowshipping with fellow
believers and following said people as
if they are the prophets of God, God's
hand-chosen prophet to thus to say thus
says the Lord for you. Those are two
different things. Like me and Albie, we
can fellowship together, read the word
together, support each other.
Albie's not my He's not my prophet. They
say we need to be we need to be united
in the the belief, that way we don't
cause division among us. Like So, if we
start picking choosing this and that and
that, then there won't be any any unity
in the congregation. It's good for us to
have one mindset on the beliefs.
Could I ask you Let me just ask you
this. Is it better to be
in unity with a group of humans or to be
in unity with the word of God.
With the word of God, yeah. Okay, so
then let me ask you this.
Can you say Jehovah is your brother?
No, Jehovah wanted us to be my friend,
yeah.
We need to be friends with Jehovah. So
you can't identify Jehovah as your
brother? No.
But you can identify Jehovah
as your father, though, correct?
Yeah, he created us, yeah, so but Okay,
did you know that there's a
Jeroboam's [clears throat] son,
Jeroboam's son
in 1 Kings 15:1 is called
Abijah, which means Jehovah is my
father, right? And these are
uh theophoric names. Theophoric names
represent either your relationship to
Jehovah or Jehovah's attributes. You see
what I'm saying? That's what theophoric
names are. So Abijah, Jehovah is my
father, that's Jeroboam's son's name.
Would you agree that Jehovah is your
father? You said yes, correct?
Yeah, in the sense that he created us,
but not like
Cuz uh
No, no, listen, I get it. You're not a
Mormon where you believe that he
physically sired you, right? Yeah, mhm.
But yet, my other question is, can you
say that Jehovah is your brother?
No, no, I've never heard that phrase
before, no. But did you know that
there's a righteous prophet, his name is
Ahijah
in 1 Kings chapter 12:15, Ahijah, he's a
righteous prophet
and his name literally means Jehovah is
my brother.
Yeah, I I think that's a little deep for
me. I never I've never
I've never studied that portion yet,
yeah.
1 Kings 12:15 and also 1 Kings 15:1. And
something to think about because we can
>> about the the magazine this guy showed
me. He's in the false prophecies. And so
is Jehovah your brother?
Cuz the you know, like if the foundation
is false, then when they ask us to trust
them, it doesn't make sense for us to
trust them because you can't trust
somebody who has lied to you in the
past. You know, and the main reason why
we're okay with you know, like with them
saying one thing and then switching it
is because now they claim that okay, we
can error in in this and that, but if
they have claimed that God is the one
who told them to do this, then I see
where you guys have a point there. I'll
give I'll give you guys that. So that's
something to really consider.
Cuz if they are wrong with that one
thing, what else are they wrong at, you
know?
>> Exactly.
Exactly.
>> [clears throat]
>> Yeah. And and and notice it's not even
Here's the Here's the key. It's not
simply about being wrong.
It's claiming to be God's prophet. Mhm.
Mhm. If you put the stamp of God, cuz
like you said all the pro- the people
God selected in the Old Testament, they
never uttered a word and say that God
said and then it turned out to be wrong.
If they did that, I think one example is
the guy who got eaten by lion or
something who believed a false prophet.
Yeah.
Yeah. The false God doesn't play with
false prophets, man.
He does not play with false prophets. Do
not play on Do not use the Lord's name.
Do not use Jehovah's name in vain,
right?
False prophets use Jehovah's name in
vain. The entire Watch Tower Society is
an entire institution
that is using Jehovah's name in vain.
So what do I do, man? Like my whole
life, you know, we we don't have friends
who are not Jehovah Witness,
you know, like my brother is a Jehovah
Witness. My whole life, like it's if if
I if this video were to come out and one
of my friends sees it, then all my
social network is
is gone. Like my Instagram followers
will go from like 300 to like Matthew
Matthew 10:34-39.
He said from 300.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey, Matthew 10:34-39
says, "Do not think that I came to bring
peace on earth. I did not come to bring
peace, but a sword. For I have come to
set a man against his father, a daughter
against her mother
and the daughter-in-law against the
mother-in-law
This guy is reading the Bible here and
this guy is
>> [laughter]
>> 300 to 100.
>> He said, "What, man? My My Instagram,
man, it's going to go from like 300 to
like 10, bro. Like what can I do?"
>> [laughter]
>> No,
it's a You You guys are You guys You
know what you guys are doing is like is
like
the ceiling is leaving my floor. I'm I'm
like thinking cuz these are stuff that
you have to act upon afterwards. You
can't just say,
"That was So I'm like I'm like thinking
five steps ahead." It's like, "You know
what this means, right?" Yes.
All right, so now let's let's get into
the scriptures seriously cuz you're
absolutely right.
>> [clears throat]
>> You're absolutely
>> [laughter]
>> You're absolutely right. I I think Jesus
mentions in this chapter something about
Instagram followers, like
you know, if you if you What What profit
a man if he, you know, gains all the
Instagram followers but loses his soul,
you know?
That's That's I think Jesus said
something like that in Matthew 10. I
might be wrong, Alby. I might be wrong.
No, I think you're spot on, man, you
know. You're spot on. It might It might
be there in the in the Greek.
Yeah, I think there's a variant to that,
but we see both copies. Okay,
>> [laughter]
>> right right right.
Praise God. But hey, but also but you'll
be in good company as well. The reason
why is because
a lot of Israel was following Jesus
until he was put to death. Then he lost
his followers, they scattered.
Let Let's read this. Let Let's read
this, too.
Um I like this right here. Persecution
will come.
Behold, I am I am sending you out as
sheep in the midst of wolves. So be wise
as serpents and innocent as doves.
Beware of men, for they will deliver you
over to courts and flog you in their
synagogues or their
uh kingdom halls.
And you will be dragged before governors
and kings for my sake to bear witness
bef- before them and the Gentiles.
So you're going to be be bearing witness
of Christ before these false
these these disbelievers and these false
prophets. When they deliver you over, do
not be anxious
how you are to speak or what you are to
say, for what you are to say will be
given to you in that hour.
When you get questioned about your
faith, when you get questioned about
where you're at, don't fear the moment
because the Holy Spirit, watch this. For
it is not you who speak, but the spirit
of your father speaking through you. The
Holy Spirit will speak through you and
give you the words to say
in the moment you are asked and pressed.
You're not going to See, Jesus doesn't
say that you won't go through these
these hard times. He says, "But you
won't be alone when you go through
this."
When these people turn on you, you won't
be alone.
He The spirit of his father will be with
you.
He goes on to say, "Brother will deliver
brother
over to death and the father his child
and children will rise against their
parents and have them put to death. And
you will be hated by all for my name's
sake."
Those Instagram followers you'll lose.
Those folks those friends you'll lose.
All because of Christ's name's sake.
Not the Watch Tower's sake. You You live
for Christ's name's sake.
Wow. But the one who endures to the end
will be saved.
When they persecute you in one town,
flee to the next. For truly I say to
you, you will not have gone through the
all the towns of Israel before the Son
of Man comes.
Wow. A disciple is not above his
teacher, nor a servant above his master.
It is enough for the disciple to be like
his his teacher
and the servant like his master.
If they have called the master of the
house Beelzebub
how much more will they malign those of
his household? So if they called Christ
if they called Christ the devil
and workers of Satan, how much more will
they malign and slander you? Wow. Yeah.
How much more? Apostate on the Oh my
god, yeah.
In 2 days you've broken the foundation
of my faith. Like
I don't know how I'm going to be able to
proceed cuz
it's it's one thing if you used to
believe and then Jehovah Witness told
you otherwise and then you go back, but
if this is the only thing I've known my
whole life
then
then what, you know? So
Yeah, well, Jesus tells you then what.
Be born again. Yep.
Let's continue this cuz I want you to to
keep to I want the words of the Lord to
continue to encourage you, brother.
Amen. He says, "So have no fear of
them."
Don't fear them.
For nothing is covered that will not be
revealed or hidden that will not be
known.
And what was covered before has now been
known to you, brother.
It's been revealed to you. You know it
now. You see it now. Oh, yeah. What I
tell you in the dark, say in the light.
And what you hear whispered, proclaim on
the housetops.
And do not fear those who kill the body,
but cannot kill the soul. Rather fear
him who can destroy both soul and body
in hell.
Are not two sparrows sold for a penny?
And not one of them will fall to the
ground apart from your father.
But even the hairs of your head are all
numbered.
Fear not. This is how you proceed.
This is how you move forward without
fear.
Fear not therefore,
you are of more value than many
sparrows.
So everyone who acknowledges me before
men, I will also acknowledge before my
father who is in heaven.
Not just the governing body, not just
the anointed class,
whoever, everyone who acknowledges me
before men, everyone [clears throat]
I also will acknowledge before my father
who is in heaven.
You'll be introduced to Jesus' father.
Not just the anointed class, you are the
anointed class. You are anointed by the
Holy Spirit.
But whoever denies me before men, I will
also deny before my father
who is in heaven.
How do you move forward? Be not afraid.
Move forward in courage. Wow. Well,
thank you very much, man. I don't know I
don't know what to say right now cuz uh
with just a few few revelation, you're
able to prove a whole ma- organization
that
claim to be the truth and can be
dismantled like this. It's
It's unheard of, you know? Like cuz in
my head I was like, "Okay, I got I got
this. I got this." And everybody will
become a Jehovah Witness. And then you
said, "No, all that is nothing when the
beginning is false word.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Like cuz you what else is wrong?
Now I have to
question pretty much every belief that I
believe whether it's grounded from
truth. Cuz if it turns out to be like I
can say, "Oh, I believe this." And I'm
sure with one
Bible verse you can show me that how
wrong I am. And I'm like, "Now what?"
And I'm
Wow.
Yeah. But hey, I I want to add I'm
telling you, man, you're not by
yourself, bro. You're not by yourself.
You got me. I'm here with you. You got
an entire
You got Well, how many there's 30 3,100
people in here watching on YouTube? All
of us are praying for you, brother. All
of us are praying for you. We are with
you. We are supporting you. You can keep
coming here if you have questions and
need support. We got you, bro. You're
not going to be by yourself.
Well, thank you very much.
I
I like your host he was just punching
me. He's like, "You're in hell. You're
in hell." I'm like, "No."
>> [laughter]
>> No way.
No way.
You know, with the Jehovah Witness we
don't believe in hell. We believe it's a
cut off. You die and that's it. No
suffering, no nothing. So
but it's okay. Well, I don't know if you
want to call somebody else. Well, I
don't know if you have a question for
me. It's up to you guys. But thank you
so much.
Well, I I I guess I do have a question.
And now you're you're the last one. I
was I was waiting all day for you, man.
You you're the one I was waiting for.
>> [laughter]
>> You're the one I was waiting for. Okay,
go ahead.
Well, so my my question for you is
now like with you seeing how
the Watch Tower is is false prophet,
with you seeing how
it is easily dismantled with scripture,
how what they say doesn't match with
scripture, and how we're able to present
scripture and present the truth,
I I want to know
what what will your next step be?
Do more research.
Basically, I want to say, "Okay, why do
why don't I celebrate this? Why do I
believe this? Why do other Christians
don't believe this?" That's That's
basically what's running in my head.
It's like "Okay, this whole time when I
see people
believing that, you know, like we need
to celebrate Easter. Why why don't we
celebrate Easter? Why You know, like uh
why don't why don't I believe that I'm
going to go to heaven? You know, like
And so forth so forth so or why don't
why why am I supposed to listen to them
without questioning?
Like you know, like you told me right
there that uh
uh like if if you have to test uh
the teaching, but we are we are taught
to like just listen even if it doesn't
make sense to a human standpoint. They
have the the Holy Spirit like hovering
on top of their head. So we just have to
follow and then later on you will see
why they gave us that direction. But if
they have lied before and I wasn't aware
of it because they were able to control
the information I have, I I need to
question everything at this point, you
know?
Yeah. For sure. Look, bro, do you have
an email?
Mhm. Yeah, it's
I I you calling my real name. I put
Jehovah Witness here to try to hide my
name but
now you're fine.
>> [laughter]
>> No, but it's uh you so you clearly can
see Maisha Ali. You just have to add a
Gmail
Now you're fine.
I I can see it. No no one no one else
can see it. I only I can see it.
>> Gotcha. Yeah, the my my name means life.
So it's maishaali@gmail.com.
Yeah, so Maisha is Swahili. It's okay.
It's my first
middle name
>> don't say it. Don't don't don't say it.
Don't say it because cuz you're I don't
I don't want you to get spammed by a
bunch of Jehovah's Witnesses that are
going to try [laughter] to spam you,
bro.
But I I was saying that like you can you
can email me and we can stay in contact,
okay?
And if you have questions or you need
some sources, I can help you out.
>> [snorts]
>> Well, thank you very much. You don't
know what Oh, go ahead. Yeah. I just
want to ask you one question.
Will you celebrate your birthday this
year then?
You know, it's weird cuz the like the
Bible We want to Hey, we want to be
there. Hey, when you celebrate your
birthday this year, we want to be there
for that celebration as well, all right?
You're already past. My birthday was
4 days ago. So it's next year now.
I Yeah, but
but but I hopefully at point I will be
more comfortable with it because
we see birthdays as being greedy or you
know, like puffed up or it's my day,
this. Forget about God. Forget about
this. It's my day. That's why we we we
tend to stay away from it. But if if I
use the my birthday to say thank you to
God for
keeping me safe for the whole year, I
don't see anything wrong with that. But
that just that thought, you know, you
don't know how many times I've shoved
this. Like, "Why am I thinking this? Why
am I thinking this?" Like, you know,
it's bad bad bad bad bad. You know, so
right right now I'm giving myself even
freedom to think of things that I've
shoved, you know,
ahead. Like, "This is going to
lead me in the wrong path. This is going
to lead me in the wrong path."
>> [clears throat]
>> And one more thing And one more And one
more thing.
Will you sing
to Jesus this year? Because you're not
allowed to in the Watch Tower Society,
but in the Book of Revelation they do.
In Revelation chapter 5 they sing a new
song to Jesus. Will you also be singing
to Jesus?
>> [laughter]
>> I I forgot you will be. That's what I
wanted to say. No, so based on what you
guys told me, I want to say yes. But you
like those things are like But you're
not allowed to You know, like you Yeah,
like what what are you talking about?
You You can You can only talk to God.
What are you talking about? Talk No, you
can only sing to Jehovah. You're not
allowed to sing worship praises to
anyone else. It's idolatry except for
Jehovah.
Which means all the inhabitants of
heaven were idolaters in Revelation
chapter 5.
Verse 7 to 13. But yeah, go ahead,
brother. We love you, man.
And I'm glad
I'm glad I was I'm glad that
I was able to be a part of this because
I heard about you not just today, but on
Wordn Eye's stream and everything. So
I'm really excited to
just be a witness of this slow
transformation as God Logic is being
used to tug at your heart by the grace
of the spirit, man. It's beautiful,
dude. You know what I mean?
>> my question will be like, is it only
just through the email? That's why I
would say, "Hey, uh so I used to believe
this. How do you debunk this?" Or can I
come and stay in queue like this and
just ask that one question and get
answered and then leave? Like how does
that work?
>> Yeah. Yeah, you can you can Look,
brother, until you fully until you
accept Christ I mean even after,
you can come up and you can come out you
can come talk to me.
Come talk to me. And I'll and I'll
continue to do my best to pour into you
and continue to give you, you know, some
scriptures and good knowledge and good
resources to help your studies, okay?
Okay. Well, I'll be looking forward to
the Hey, if it's okay, dude,
follow follow me on
on my Instagram as well. And I'll follow
you right back. My Instagram is Biblical
Mechanics. And you know, feel free to
hit me up, too, man. Yeah, it's Biblical
Mechanics on Instagram.
Let me look for Biblical Mechanic.
My wife is famous than me, so she's
>> [laughter]
>> How much How much How much she got? 600?
No, you know, you know girls get bunch
of followers than men. They do. They do.
They do. Like if [laughter] she post a
picture, she get like 300 likes. And she
post a picture with me, she get
two likes. Be like, "Bro, what the hell?
WHAT
WHAT [laughter] IS ALL THESE PEOPLE NOT
LIKING PICTURES?" LIKE, "Come on, man."
Yeah, Biblical Mechanic. So my wife I I
just followed you on my wife. So I'll
I'll find you right there.
>> I'll I'll
I'm going to follow I'll follow you
right back. Oh, what what Is your Is
your wife in the house right now?
Yeah, she's right here. She's She's
>> [laughter]
>> Hi.
What is What does she What does she What
do you think about everything that
you've been hearing so far?
It's It's eye-opening, I can say.
Yeah. Praise God. Yeah.
>> Yeah, no. The reason that they they they
know that the the theology, but since
they don't get to repeat it as often at
the at the Kingdom Hall, it's sometimes
they just say, "Oh, my husband, whatever
he says, I'll go." So
Like yeah, it's more emotional with them
than actual doctrine like because it's
just a community, but when it comes to
us men, we have to know the stuff. Yeah.
>> And because we will teach it to our
fellow Jehovah Witnesses and to
to the other people out there, but
Yeah. [snorts]
>> Right now, I'm not I'm not even sure
that if I feel comfortable teaching
you know, like what I'm sure you guys
can debunk 1914 like that, like you
know, like I like So so I don't know
what to say at this point. Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, it's all right, man. You So look,
I'm I'm live every Monday, Wednesday,
Friday. Mhm. Okay? You have Alby's
Instagram. You have my email. So we can
we can stay in contact. You can stay in
contact with Alby. And um
we'll we'll just we'll continue pouring
into you. We'll continue growing and as
like listen to the voice of the Lord,
brother. Listen to the voice of the
Lord. You are no longer asleep, but you
are now awake. You're not asleep
anymore.
Okay? So now you're able to the scales
have come off. The scales have fallen
off your eyes like it did Paul's eyes
that day when he was blinded. The scales
are off your eyes now. Now you can see
the serpent for what he is. You can see
the enemy for what he is, and you can
see the falsehood for what it is. So
protect It's your job You're You're the
man of your house. Protect Mhm. your
family with truth and right doctrine,
grabbing hold to the Lord Jesus, the
true Lord, okay, for who he truly is in
the true gospel, not this fake gospel
the Watchtower gave us. All right? So
like I said, as the days go on, we'll
continue to show you and and and pour
into you of what the Bible says, who
Jesus truly is, what the true gospel is,
all these other issues, heaven and hell,
what What's all this? We can We We'll
pour into you, brother. I got you. Well,
thank you very much. I really appreciate
it. Thank you.
>> [laughter]
>> Of course. God bless you, man. Much love
to you and your family, man. Thank you.
Bye.
God bless you, brother. Mhm.
I never know how to exit this. I got
you.
>> [laughter]
>> Your logic, man, that was amazing, bro.
Thank you so much for inviting me to be
a part of this, brother. God bless you,
man.
>> [laughter]
[snorts]
>> I was just
There was a moment that I went like
silent.
When you were talking to him because I
was like, "Dang, man."
It [snorts] seemed like he like reverted
back
to like that cult mindset, that bot
mode, and it was just like, "Dang, did
we lose him?" Mhm. You know?
Cuz I was We've been praying for him
ever since.
Praying for him, and so it's like
>> [snorts and laughter]
>> uh I didn't care. I didn't care how,
you know,
uh
how off he was sounding, I didn't care
how
um
like how many excuses he was giving to
the Watchtower, I did I didn't care. I
was like, "We're We're not stopping.
We are not stopping.
>> [snorts]
>> We're not stopping, and we were able to
break through by the power of the Holy
Spirit, we were able to break through.
And he was able to like God just reached
him and and got him.
>> [laughter]
>> Bro,
got him.
And so it's just like it's it's just
I just thank God, man. I just thank God.
I just thank God, bro. And brother, if
it wasn't for
the grace that was put in your heart
regarding 1 Peter 4:8 says, "Love covers
a multitude of sins." God filled your
heart with so much love towards him
>> [gasps]
>> that there wasn't much that he could do
without you going after him, man,
because the Lord sent you that way. And
praise God for that. [clears throat]
Yeah. It was beautiful, man. Yeah, man.
God is good. God is good. I just thank
the Lord. I just thank you, Lord.
I just thank you, Lord, for using this
ministry. I thank you, Lord, for
bringing hearts to you. I thank you,
Lord, for removing the scales off of
people's eyes and truly reaching them,
using us to do it, equipping us with the
words, with the right attitude, with the
right heart to reach your people, to
reach your sheep.
All glory to God. All glory is yours,
Lord.
All right, Charles. That's a good place
to end it. You guys see
um
when when we we go hard, we go hard,
man. When we go hard, we we do this. We
ain't letting go. And so
Friday, we will be back. We will be back
Friday. We are attacking this cult, this
Watchtower Society, this cult that is
lying to millions of people.
And you can thank
the Jehovah's Witnesses on TikTok
who who who inspired this.
You Y'all did this. You guys woke me up
to you guys. Now I'm over here pulling
up Watchtower magazines like it's
Hadith.
Y'all Y'all did this.
Y'all did this.
And so now by the grace and power of the
Holy Spirit, by the might and wrath of
God, we're going to come out of come
after you, and we're going to destroy
this false kingdom, this kingdom of
lies. We're going to destroy you
in Jesus' name. Amen.